on vient y croyez vous qu'il y ait deux
papas peluche le vôtre haut du corps
comptait bien sur vos droits
wada attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]
non
e
raté encore là c'est mieux à vous lancer
de javelot de mon enfant j'étais un
champion j'ai même reçu le javelot
d'argent en 1900 et quelqu'un a
longtemps regardé au riez riez je vais à
la ville mes amours tout je vous parie
5/4 abeilles chacun que je vous parle
tous les deux au javelot 100 membres
oui mais ton chacun 5 carats met sur la
table et celui de nous trois qui
atteindra le centre de la simca grade
tous les gars à l'aise vous êtes
d'accord d'accord
[Musique]
et
un hussard j'ai peur que nous perdions
notre à mol je vais m'entraîner et toi
t'as truc de pata truc j'ai trouvé le
truc je vais me faire un javelot spécial
jarre voulons tricia matap l'ujap a
dachnak aulas lyon là je veux pas perdre
mon camp allemand
commenge d'efforts à je sors avec ses
abdos à tête chercheuse
je suis sûr de gagner parce que tu vas
tu verra plus tard
o o
et oh
quand ça n'est pas que deux vitesses et
un jeu sans champions que le meilleur
gagne
un bel honneur monsieur bougon maman
d'abord le plus jeune vas-y pas ta zik
ça n'est pas très régulier ça vous
invite à faire tomber moi
qu'en pensez-vous pas tacle ou tous
chacun se débrouille
allez-y à moi
[Musique]
à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
pata plus je ne vous trompez pas compter
bien sûr vous toi et moi dans votre
attention
il nous manque un
[Musique]